which brings us to our Twitter question
of the day we asked is the force with
Disney their role out of this has been
masterful leaking photos leaking news
about Harrison Ford's participation our
answer with our answer first one yes it
is on top of frozen Disney has created a
dream merchandising pipeline even Hasbro
envies let it force Lexus and I can't
even talk about that we're done with
that move you gotta move on next one
Disney is a money making machine besides
adding these wonderful franchises it
keeps recycling their own and they've
done an amazing job of actually moving
star wars on to YouTube here's a third
answer it comes from 1bh greeley on
twitter who cares on solo and the
Wookiee Millennium Falcon yes for those
of you on Bloomberg radio brendan is
losing let's go to Jack Lockhart who's
gonna really them with the money
question for disney right now there is a
James who is three years old well
grandpa be taking him to Star Wars
that's all the Disney people would like
to know the grandpa will be taking them
so will his father who is a real star
wars family a fan that actually used to
work at Disney at one point Josh you
think this is except don't you happy I
mean it's it's gonna be interesting to
to go back and say do the special
effects from the first parts of this
year yeah work relative to today's
absolutely what a fanboy comment but i
also think more broadly you know you
have a movie it turns into mythology
when you can move it into three
generations if father can pass it on to
son and then to daughter that it becomes
that's always been disney yes right i
mean even the recycling of the animated
this yeah right we're do a shout-out to
lawrence kasdan and the best Star Wars
The Empire Strikes Back Star Wars is
about story and script and not about
blowing up things